es mutet an wie eine zeitreise
doch wir sind im jahr 2022 im norden der
ukraine
unser weg durch den krieg führt uns
immer wieder an checkpoints an denen wir
mutige männer treffen die großes
vorhaben es geht so sagen sie immer
wieder nur die verteidigung europas
wir stehen hier vor einem sogenannten
blog post das heißt das sind solche
kontrollpunkte selbstverteidigungs
punkte wo sich zivilisten aus dem ort
versammelt haben und versuchen quasi
widerstand oder wie soll man sagen
verteidigungskräfte zu mobilisieren
rhodia ist 53 jahre alt und eigentlich
fahren jetzt ist er im krieg und zeigt
uns seine waffe ein jagdgewehr mit
oldtimer status
das ist eine simson
1949 ev jahren mit patronen gott bewahre
falls irgend ein russe kommt werden wir
schießen wir müssen unsere leute
verteidigen
als die männer erfahren dass wir aus
deutschland kommen bitten sie uns um
hilfe die land tut das seit monaten
wir brauchen schutzausrüstungen
schutzwesten und helme sie sehen ja
unter welchen bedingungen wir hier
arbeiten wir sind freiwillige bekommen
kein geld sie brauchen nachtsichtgeräte
und auch warmes schuhwerk
tut europa tut deutschland genug für sie
ein ukrainer mit deutscher panzer fast
vor wochen war dieses bild undenkbar
mittlerweile hat berlin 1000
panzerfäuste geschickt
auch 500 flugabwehrsysteme sind bereits
geliefert
2700 flugabwehrwaffen vom typ strehler
soll noch kommen die bundesregierung hat
ihren kurs gewechselt
viele haben ja gesagt 48 stunden ist
kiew in russischer hand die ukraine
kämpfte weiter und in dieser situation
ist der internationale druck der moral
die moralische verpflichtung so
gestiegen das glaube ich kann es da
schon gemerkt hat ich muss die flucht
nach vorne drin und ich muss eine
kehrtwende um 180 grad verführen doch
die ukraine will vielmehr panzer für den
kampf am boden stehen auf dem
wunschzettel
kriegsschiffe um die christen zu sichern
und kampfjets für die luftwaffe doch
europa und nato fürchten die eskalation
entweder liefert man das sagen ein
bisschen heimlich und das ist nicht klar
woher diese flugzeuge kommen wenn es
öffentlich debattiert wird ist die sache
tut dafür hat russland so viel druck
aufgebaut und das ist dann eben auch die
gefahr dass russland zum beispiel dann
anfängt in polen solche flughäfen zu
beschießen mit raketen auf denen diese
flugzeuge möglicherweise an die ukraine
geliefert werden wir fahren weiter nach
süden
witali und atem haben uns mitgenommen
sie wollen nach odessa am schwarzen meer
und von dort hilfsgüter in die umkämpfte
hauptstadt kiew bringen
heute sind wir unterwegs mit einem
gepanzerten fahrzeug man sieht hier die
scheiben sind zentimeter dick das auch
dringend nötig wir fahren direkt an ihr
vorbei richtung besser die männer sind
eigentlich in der sicherheitsbranche
tätig jetzt sind sie humanitäre helfer
im krieg
wir versuchen hauptsächlich menschen aus
kiel herauszuholen jetzt holen wir
medikamente aus odessa ab wir können uns
sind dagegen gut aus wir wissen wie wir
fahren müssen um nicht unter beschuss zu
geraten
auch helfer können hilflos seien in
diesem krieg
immer wieder greift die russische armee
städte an zivilisten werden zu
zielscheiben die stadt mariupol im osten
des landes
hunderttausende sind hier eingeschlossen
und die welt schaut ratlos
[Musik]
wir sind angekommen in odessa der
schäden am schwarzen meer
hier treffen wir daniels allem in der
ukraine ist er eigentlich ein bekannter
fernsehmoderator jetzt trägt der uniform
hat sich freiwillig gemeldet um seine
stadt zu verteidigen für das zaudern des
westens für daniel jedes verständnis
wir leben doch auf einem planeten der
erde heißt wenn dein nachbar schmerzen
erleidet und das tun wir menschen
sterben kinder sterben wenn du dann nur
zuschauer ist und nichts tust dann
beginnst du auch ein verbrechen
viele hier fordern dass die nato die
ukraine vor luftangriffen geschützt
am wochenende starben mehr als 30
menschen über 100 werden verletzt als
russland ein militärstützpunkt beschießt
gerade mal 20 kilometer von der grenze
zu polen entfernt
ukraine präsident selensky nutzt die
bilder für seine forderung
ich wiederhole es wenn sie unseren
luftraum nicht schließen wird es eine
frage der zeit bevor russische raketen
auf ihr territorium fallen auf die
häuser von menschen auf nato territorium
wenn man eine flugverbotszone
einrichten würde das heißt man würde die
lufthoheit über den ukrainischen himmel
de facto erreichen das heißt wenn ein
russisches flugzeug in diesen diese zone
einen luftraum eindringen würde müssten
nato-flugzeuge ihm signalisieren du bist
hier nicht willkommen es abdrängen und
wenn es sich nicht abbringen lässt muss
man das abschießen die analyse die die
nato getroffen hat ist so sagen wenn wir
das machen gehen wir in einen direkten
konflikt mit russland
wir sind kurz vor kiel die hauptstadt
wehrt sich um nicht von russischen
streitkräften eingekesselt zu werden
doch kiew gibt nicht auf am westlichen
stadtrand stehen sie immer wieder unter
beschuss und leben seit fast drei wochen
im keller anna und ihre kinder warten
hier dass der krieg vorüber geht dennoch
flucht bedeutet lebensgefahr
gestern haben sie busse beschossen die
menschen über einen korridor in
sicherheit bringen sollten
eine frau mit ihrem sohn ist gestorben
er war 16 jahre alt
über drei millionen menschen sind aus
der ukraine nach westen geflüchtet
mindestens noch mal so viele sind als
vertriebene im eigenen land unterwegs
vertriebene eines krieges der keine
gnade kennt die humanitäre katastrophe
ist längst da ob europa hilflos
[Musik]
eine der extrem bitteren und
frustrierenden erkenntnisse in dem krieg
ist dass
die unterstützung der westlichen staaten
in gewissem maße begrenzt ist
wir sind in kiew auf dem freiheitsplatz
spielt das philharmonische orchester die
hymne europas
ode an die freude
es ist eine mahnung sie nicht zu
vergessen aber sie spielen auch für sich
selbst gegen die ohnmacht die stille und
die angst
[Musik]